foreign
[Music]
and I'm going to talk about developing
internal tools for multilingual teams
specifically teams that use Python and r
to get started I want to talk about
pizza
imagine you're having a couple of
friends over for dinner and you need to
prepare them something the easiest thing
to do is to prepare them the same meal
however they're both pretty fussy eaters
do you make two entirely different meals
with all the extra ingredients prep time
and aggravation no if you make pizza
because even if you make a margarita
pizza for one friend and a Hawaiian for
the other they still have the same base
the same core ingredients
what does pizza have to do with iron
python
the prospect of developing a tool in
both R and python can feel like you're
about to prepare two entirely different
meals it's twice the effort twice the
cognitive load and can take a lot more
time
how can we take the principle of our
pizza party that is making two different
meals with the same base and apply it to
developing bilingual tools
this is a question I think about a lot
in my job so I work at Bumble we are the
company behind the dating and social
networking apps but do bumble and fruits
my job is to develop internal packages
for our data analysts
now most of our analysts work in Python
however some of our projects are done in
r this means some of our internal
packages are developed in both languages
but what do we need internal packages
well internal packages can help to
automate and standardize procedures that
are specific to your organization for
example an internal package might
automatically apply company styling to a
report or enable a user to connect to an
internal database in the correct way
tomorrow for Emily reader is our studio
global talk
internal packages are kind of like
members of your organization with
specific jobs to do
but why developing both Python and r the
answer is simple in a multilingual
organization we want everyone to follow
the same internal procedures regardless
of the language that they are using
the question I will try to address today
is what strategies can we use to make
developing tools simultaneously with
python and R easier
in truth this is a very big topic with
lots of branching ideas
therefore today I will focus on three
ideas that have helped me to develop
bilingual tools
the first idea I want to talk about is
building identical genetic functions but
what is a generic function let's look at
this from the r perspective generic
functions are very common in the r
language for example functions like
print or summary or tidy from the boom
package the really cool thing about
generics is that they behave in
different ways depending on the class of
an object that's passed to them
under the hood this is achieved using a
process called method dispatch
as an internal developer you might want
to build a package that uses custom
internal classes and you may want your
users to be able to call methods like
print or summary on them
and in some cases you may even want to
Define your own generic functions
let's take a look at what generic
functions look like in code
to do this we'll create a new package
which will provide one function say
hello
and this will print a nice friendly
greeting to an object that we pass to it
to start we Define our generic function
say hello and in the function body we
make a call to use method passing it the
name of our generic as a string and
that's it that's our generic but now we
need a class specific implementation of
this function
and to do this let's make one for a data
frame
and to do it we will use dot notation
say Hello dot data frame
and in this new function we print a nice
friendly greeting
and now if you want to catch all
implementation say hello we will use the
default pseudo class say Hello dot
default
okay now we know how our package is
going to work
we need a python version
can we write our python version in the
same way as our R version
and the answer is yes
to do this we're going to import single
dispatch from the functions module
and unlike R we actually start by
defining our fallback method to say
hello
and we decorate it with single dispatch
now if you're not familiar with
decorators think of them as wrapper
functions that change the behavior of a
function
and now we're going to create a data
frame implementation of say hello in
Python using a data frame object from
the pandas Library
and we do this with the register
function and here I am passing that data
frame to the register function
and there we have it but what have we
actually achieved here
well we have two different tools one in
r one in Python that have the same
Foundation as say hello generic with a
data frame implementation
so both of my packages work the same
conceptually this is good for end users
they get a similar API to work with
regardless of whether they're using our
python
but also my code is physically quite
similar so when I go and make a change
in the python version of my code I know
where to go and make that change in the
r version of my code
so building identical generic functions
is going to save me a lot of time and
effort the next idea I will talk about
is identical error handling with classes
let's look at this from the python
perspective
now if you're a python user you're
probably familiar with these kinds of
exceptions final found error zero
division error and key error
exceptions in Python are themselves
classes that inherit from other
exception classes and you can probably
already tell that the names of these
exceptions are quite descriptive they
form part of the error message
now as an internal developer you can
create your own custom and total errors
you can give them really descriptive
names and the error messages that they
give can be as well specific as you want
even telling the user where to go for
help if that error has been thrown
the powerful thing about exceptions in
Python is that they can be handled
explicitly for example with a try accept
statement I asked python to try running
some code and in the event of a specific
error in this case a far not found error
I can run an alternative block of code
this gives me maximum control over how
my code handles failure
okay so we're building a python package
and we are handling errors in this way
but can we handle errors in the same way
in our R packages
the answer is yes but let's look at some
basic error handling in our first
if you're an R user you may have seen
one of these two functions stop from
base R and abort from the r line package
both functions signal an error
and in R if we want to handle errors in
our code we can use something like a try
catch function but notice here on the
second line the error Handler is a
function that will execute in response
to any error it's not designed to handle
a specific error and this is a problem I
now have a lot less control over my code
and more importantly my Python and our
packages handle failure in very
different ways
how can we overcome this
well the answer to this is within the
abort function from arlang
let me illustrate this with an example
I'm going to create a new function about
credentials missing
and within the call to our line abort I
am going to give a specific class name
here it's Error credentials missing
now the really great thing about error
functions in R is that you can create an
equivalent
python exception
so as an internal developer you have
your python exceptions and you have your
R error functions they're one and the
same so when you make a change in one
language you know where to make that
change in the other language
but what if we gained by giving our
error a class name well let's go back to
try catch you can see here on the second
line I can now write a specific error
Handler for my new era error credentials
missing
and now my python package and my r
package handle failure in the same way
I want to round off this section on
errors by talking about error chaining
in essence error training is throwing an
error in response to another error one
use for this is to give a high level
context to a lower level error
doing this in Python is very easy for
example you can give your original error
an alias here I'm giving it the anus e
and then I'm raising another exception
from that original exception
and this gives me a kind of double error
message I get my original error and then
python tells me that this error caused
another error
can we emulate this in r
the answer is yes
now the way that we're going to do this
is we're going to use try fetch from the
rlang package instead of a try catch
and in my error Handler I'm going to
pass my condition object to the abort
function
specifically the parent argument
and here I get a kind of double error
message
and there we have it our Python and our
packages now conduct error training in
the same way
the third idea I want to talk about is
creating your own internal wrappers
but what is the internal wrapper
well it's a package written in one
language that wraps functionality from
another language
but why would you want to create your
own internal wrapper well imagine a
scenario where a piece of functionality
is available in one language but not the
other a well-known example is a
statistical model that's released as an
r package but not a python package
but you want all of your analysts to be
able to access that functionality
another scenario you might encounter is
that both languages have their own
implementation of a piece of
functionality like a statistical model
but maybe the underlying computations
aren't quite the same
and therefore your analysts get
different results
okay let's kick this section off by
looking at how we call python from R
there are many ways to do this my method
of choice is the reticulate package
reticulate gives you a number of
different ways to call python code in
your r package let's look at a couple of
examples
now the first example is importing
python modules into R this works really
well if the python code you're trying to
access is contained within a python
package
and to do this I use the import function
from reticulate I gave it the name of my
module here I'll call it Pi module and I
assign it to a variable and now I can
access functions from that module using
this dollar sign notation
now a really good tip for when you're
doing this in an r package is to create
a global reference to your python
package
and then you can use it throughout your
code
notice here I'm not actually importing
anything yet
I'm going to specify how my python
module is imported in the onload
function this will execute when my
library is loaded
and here I'm specifying delay load to
true and what this does is it gives my
end user the ability to specify their
own custom python virtual environment to
use with my package
another way that you can use Python code
in your r package is to Source python
files this might work well if the code
you're trying to access is contained
within a python script
to do this I'm going to use a python
file here it's called add.pi which is
contained in my r package and inside
that file I Define a new function add to
and now I will use Source python from
the reticulate package and then I can
access the add to function
okay we've called python from R now
let's call R from python
again there are many ways to do this my
method of choice is the r Pi 2 package
RPI 2 gives you a number of different
ways to call our code from your python
package let's look at some examples
the first method is to import our
libraries into python to do this we're
going to import the import R function
from rpi2
and then in this example we're actually
going to import a base R itself which we
can import like any other Library
to access a function from base R we'll
use this top notation here I am
accessing the sum function
now to use this function I'm going to
have to do a little bit of work
sometimes when you're using rpi2 you
need to convert objects between R and
python
in this example I need to convert my
python list into an R vector
I can do that using the int Vector
function from RPI 2.
you can check out the rpi2 documentation
for more tips on object conversion
another way to access our code from
python using RPI 2 is to create new
functions and access them from the r
environment this approach works really
well when you have multiple computation
steps that need to happen in r
now to do this we're going to first
import the r objects module from our pi2
we're then going to Define our code as a
string here I'm just creating a new
function that returns 1. I then execute
that R code using the r function from R
objects
and then I can access that new function
using Global n and assign it to a
variable a narrow Pi func is actually a
function that I can execute
now a really great utility that rpo2
gives you is the ability to define a
temporary package structure
and we can do this by importing the stap
function from rpi2 and just like before
we store our R code as a string and then
we use stap to execute that code and
then we can access functions from that
code using this dot notation
so this approach works really well when
you are concerned about issues like
namespace conflicts
okay now for the bad news
cross-language rappers have their own
technical quirks and headaches
for example you have twice the number of
environments to think about your users
will need to have access to both Python
and R and your packages will need to
deal with the relevant dependencies
from personal experience reticulate is a
lot more explicit about how it handles
python environments whereas with RPI 2
you need to do a little bit more of the
work yourself
now another issue is object conversion
sometimes to work with cross-language
rappers you need to handle the
conversion of an object from one
language to another like you saw with
RPI too
and a third issue are error messages
sometimes when an error occurs in the
language that is being wrapped the error
message doesn't come through in its
entirety which can frustrate your
efforts to create nice helpful error
messages
but with all this being said
cross-language rappers are a really
useful tool in your internal toolkit
they can deal with issues of missing
functionality or inconsistent outputs
between languages
and there we have it three different
ways to build bilingual tools without
having to design two entirely different
solutions
the goal of each of these ideas is to
make the development process and the
maintenance process much easier for you
if you're an internal tool developer
working in a bi-local organization I
would encourage you to seek out these
programming Concepts and ideas that
could help to bridge the gap between
Python and r
ultimately the goal of this is to make
your life as a developer much much
easier
thank you for listening and happy
developing
[Music]